live from Santa Monica beach the 2001
IFP West Independent Spirit Awards and
now your host for the afternoon the man
who gave bad taste a good name John
Waters
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you welcome to the IFP West
Independent Spirit Awards it's sort of
like the Betty Ford Clinic with drinks
isn't it you know it's nice to be asked
back you can never have too many careers
I kind of feel tonight like Alan Carr
meets a dick clark who ages i think the
real reason they asked me back is
because i'm the only name they could
find that wasn't nominated for something
tonight but that's okay because being a
loser is edgy and
and that's what we're here to celebrate
tonight edginess everybody wants to be
edgy I mean that the coolest theatres
only play edgy films the hippest
distributors brag but only they know how
to release a film with edge I work with
a film festival the Provincetown film
festival that gives out the edge award
the filmmaker on the edge award so um
even the Spirit Awards has been called
the edgiest kind of TV show on so we're
gonna try to hope to live up to that
today you know I think we're off to a
good start because I get a hundred and
twenty five magazines a month and I read
them all and there's films nominated to
tonight that I've never heard of
basically since I'm the host I get to
give the producers ideas about what they
should do next year to even make it edgy
er I think that's very important you
know even though my ideas are not
cinematically correct I think we should
send all the pick through gift baskets
left behind today and dump them on the
lawns of the nominees of today who
didn't show up especially if they're you
know where tomorrow night you know all
the presenters should announce their
addictions as they come onstage
I'm John Waters and I'm the robert
downey jr. of cigarettes I'm proud to
share that with you tonight you know you
can't blackmail a celebrity who admits
everything if movies but if movie stars
spilled the beans on themselves first
the tabloid press wouldn't be outside
taking photos of you that they were
later used to illustrate made-up stories
about your marital breakups let's be
honest and admit that all of us
encourage teenagers to see r-rated
movies the Future Independent Spirit
Awards are sneaking into an r-rated
movie as I speak what kind of teenager
accepts a restricted rating if he wants
to be in show business one who will
never make a film that's who you know
since since the golden globes served
liquor and the TV critics always speak
highly of that and we serve liquor all
the time I thought next year we should
give out bongs
imagine movie star bad trips you know
anorexia meets the munchies who knows
maybe Harrison Ford would come
hire somebody to host next year that
will be guaranteed to lose it on stage
don't you think Elizabeth Taylor this
year at the Golden Globes secretly
copied Ally Sheedy spray sauna from a
fear back I I do and they were great
both great moments and televisions steel
promotional ideas from European shows
the Sun London's most rabid tabloid
newspaper has a dog named Charlie that's
trained to smell cocaine and they bring
Charlie to movie star premieres and
having lunch at celebrities on the red
carpet imagine tonight everybody running
that dog chasing people back to the
limos get that dog away from me
now some edge advice for all the stars
here today well you know not washing
your hair is not enough anymore you've
got to keep reinventing yourself so your
image will attract a younger angry or
even more insane group of filmmakers
that are coming up next you know if if
you're really known for being sweet
become a monster for the day you know
going against type always works you know
out front on the red carpet say you know
oh I you know I'm much more independent
than those sellouts inside nobody saw my
last movie and I'm proud of it you know
bring an alarming date if you're if
you're
if you're part of a famous couple swap
partners and arrive at different times
you'll really get coverage you know if
you're gay and you're trying to hide it
Rinne Anna bring Anna Nicole Smith you
know that'll confuse the issue really
you know every year I invite Don Knotts
to be my date and I mean hey we all have
it tight and
[Applause]
every year his people make really polite
excuses and this year his agents have
done right at the right apart for Don
John and I didn't have the nerve to tell
him I use the casting couch let's talk
about fashion movie stars you cheap
bastards pay for your outfits you can
afford them you know free clothes are
for the poor not actors donate the money
your free outfit you're wearing today
cost to the homeless or better yet the
fashion less a new trendy minority be
nice to your independent fans believe me
they haven't been waiting out front on
the bleachers for three days to get your
autograph their home designing insane
websites about your personal life
one night I went out in Baltimore and
the next day on the web it said John
Waters was gonna bar last night he took
a leak didn't wash his hands and shook
hands with fans I thought wow there's a
fan who cares you know be nice to these
lunatics they usually turn into
journalists
and they'll some advice for today's
nominees be a bad loser nobody ever is
you know sobs uncontrollably when your
name isn't called the cameras might stay
on you instead you know rush into the
press tent afterwards and give your
planned acceptance speech even though
you lost
better yet steal the winner's wallet
while he or she is on stage you know
believe me winners never watch their bag
in moments of glory now if you are a
winner let's get one thing straight
none of this oh I was in the bathroom
when they called my name
one would think a serious nominee would
eliminate before coming to award show
being a bad winner is even edgier than
being a bad loser
thank nobody on stage whip out your
prepared speech on your fancy expensive
stationery monogrammed and read the
three words you've written I deserved it
quote from memory the only negative
review you got in the world and named
the critic leave immediately after your
acceptance speech not caring about what
Ward's Awards follow yours and the next
day release a statement to the press
with your opinions on who came in second
third and fourth makes special fun of
who came in fifth finally try to pick up
somebody today you know does anybody get
lucky at award shows do the winners ever
go home with a losers date do people get
laid at the IFP Awards I mean I need to
know how around you means show business
people have loose morals all award shows
are too long get busy you've got the
time this is Hollywood
and now to present our first award
please welcome from oh brother where art
thou and from when Brendon met Trudy
Holly Hunter and Gabriel Byrne
[Applause]
[Music]
the nominees for Best Supporting Actor
are Willem Dafoe for shadow of the
vampire don't expect realism there but
no what do you mean don't cheat me
martyr you will stay away from her you
will stay away from my troupe
I will finish my picture this is hardly
your picture any longer
[Music]
Cole Hauser for Tigerland
private boss you are the only man that
speaks English you speak only to the man
who identifies himself as the
interpreter is that understood good
private Paxton you are the Vietcong
those boys come through here their
objective is to find the VC sympathizer
in other words you private Paxton they
have five minutes you tell them nothing
gary oldman for The Contender Blanco has
an extra player to just come on the work
stage with perfect for them Margret
Thatcher didn't have perfect credentials
the world respected her the world
accepted Margaret Thatcher because they
knew she had to answer to Ronald Reagan
a woman better be pretty damn qualified
to have nobody to answer to and Lena
plaint Hansen is not that look me in the
eyes and tell me that the Laine Hanson
is your first choice the vice presidency
Giovanni Ribisi for the gift good man I
hate my dad he's getting the mom and me
yeah every kid needs a hit with a belt
sometime you gotta try to get past his
wall are you talking about it hon you
need to talk about you daddy why don't
you tell me why I hate him you're the
goddamn sidekick huh here's a goddamn
psychic Billy Dee Williams for the visit
you didn't get borne deserving something
you're a man first Alex but a man knows
how to take responsibility we have to
take responsibility for our own lives
Alex that's why so many of your people
live the type of lives they live because
they don't want to take responsibility
for their own lives you have to be a
real man
and the award goes to willem dafoe
shadow
[Applause]
[Music]
if I do this quick do I get a free TV
I'm surprised I never see him I do want
to thank some people this is great thank
you it was really a fun show to do
and this is just gravy I'd like to
acknowledge some people Stephen Katz for
his screenplay very witty and and a
great concede a great rip off of a
Nosferatu Elias marriage or his passion
and his great visual style ooh bulk for
a cinematography of fellow nominee this
evening this afternoon who else we go a
Nick Cage and Saturn films for getting
the film made Lionsgate for taking care
of it in its distribution John Malkovich
the actors all the design people I had a
great set up in this film the costume
and the makeup were everything I'd also
like to thank some people that helped me
day to day Michelle Stern least Allman
Phyllis Carlisle Kelly Bush Carrie Balak
and above all my friends and colleagues
at the Wooster group in New York City
thank you
[Applause]
he's currently packing them in in
momento she's about to direct her first
feature please welcome Joe Pantoliano
and Elena Douglas
[Music]
hey Ileana and I are here tonight to
present the first award for Best
Screenplay but first we've been asked to
explain a new element of the Spirit
Award yeah starting in about five
minutes and every half an hour after
that you're gonna be required to vote
somebody at your table out of the tent
it's unfair we know but it's what our TV
audience at home wants to say I don't
know you know it's five is a hell of a
show I'd like to be on it I mean eat a
rat to make a million dollars I know it
sounds like working for avi Lerner I
mean you know that's not so bad living
in tents I know you tell him to go try
do a low-budget movie and live in a
three banger for five weeks yeah I mean
god I wouldn't mind eating a rat have
you ever eaten mikaelsons catering it's
a good thing I've got sag insurance
speaking of sag make sure to eat
everything on your plate is the probably
last decent meal less actors will ever
have okay so let's start forming your
alliances now and don't Bogart the wine
unless you want to end up in the parking
lot yeah well give out the awards while
we are all still here to enjoy it yeah I
didn't want to be here Jennifer Tilly
could have been in my spot okay okay and
the nominees for Best Screenplay are
David Gordon Green for George Washington
Ross flavin and Michel McGruder for
Tigerland
Gina Prince Lightwood for love and
basketball
and Jordan Walker Pearlman for the visit
and younger for boiler room and the
spirit award goes to okay Best first
screenplay Geena prints blood
[Applause]
you
thank you very much um actually just had
a baby three weeks ago so this is so
this one in a few things that's got me
out of the house so thank you very much
I just want to thank a couple people
Sundance who just gave the script new
life after every studio turned it down
they've just been behind me ever since
day one so thank you Sam kit at 40 acres
who came to reading and believed in that
in the movie Mike De Luca who again was
the only only studio that believed in
the project and just has been really
great
and then just incredible crew and my
amazing cast Oh mines tonigh the two
leads who are here just made it just a
wonderful experience and finally my
husband who's at home with the baby just
thank you for believing in me from day
one
thank you she put the sugar in sugar
town and he stopped traffic in traffic
please welcome Rosanna Arquette and Don
Cheadle
[Music]
[Applause]
we are here to present the award for
best feature under $500,000 and how to
filmmakers prove they spend so little
receipts
we brought the paperwork from Chuck and
bucks just to give you an idea
okay here's film stock that's zero
shooting on digital you know save them a
couple hundred bucks right there watch
they apparently spent on KY jelly one
hundred and fifty two dollars lollipops
eighty-seven dollars DVDs thirty-six
dollars
Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf runs eleven
hundred and sixty eight no no he didn't
that they didn't he worked pro boner I
remember a Korean shot no no no no here
we go see read the alleged crane shot no
crane really tall camera operator we
swear and now the nominees who prove
that having a natural gift for
storytelling it's telling ain't got
nothing to do with money these
filmmakers represent the future of
independent film and the nominees are
bunny
writer-director me attract injure
producer Rebecca's son and shine and me
attract injure we're just trying to see
more of what you can do as far as
endurance goes okay go ahead
it doesn't matter just keep moving
[Music]
Chuck and buck director
Miguel Arteta writer Mike White producer
Matthew Greenfield you know we're having
some people over tomorrow night it's a
little party for Charlie's promotion
yeah I should have remembered that yeah
you should come it'll be great
I'll give you directions you know I can
find it
what time people are coming around 10:00
10:30 it starts at 8:00 whatever that'll
be great okay everything put together
director Marc Forster writers Adam for
gosh captain lloyd burns and Marc
Forster producer Sean first fantastic I
kind of knew it was a boy they just keep
cool
grooves writer director Greg Harrison
producer Danielle Wren food
[Applause]
[Music]
our song writer director Jim McKay
produces Jim McKay Paul s mazhai and
Diana e Williams
[Applause]
they need to be having some beans and
rice frijoles arroz con crema s el
primero helado we've--we No
mmm we feel don't even know what y'all
even saying in Spanish Joycelyn you like
chocolate with a vanilla swirl nah
girl please I'm full on chocolate and
the Spirit Award goes to
yeah Chuck and buck
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I just wanted to say I was
walking home the other night outside a
bar and these guys were like joking back
and I like walked over and this guy was
like that's the worst movie I've ever
seen and then he was like no it's a good
movie but it was worst movie I've ever
seen and I was when I got home I was
kind of bummed out but as so maybe if
that happens again I'll have this and
I'll be like well it wasn't the worst
movie but thanks a lot thank you thank
you so much we there's so many people
that contributed to this movie and I
just need to name a few of them are
incredible cast Mike White Chris Weitz
loop antivirus Beth called Paul Weitz
are incredible in committed crew blow up
pictures Jason Cleon and Joanna Vicente
Amir Mallon Patrick goddamn rat Jonah
and everyone at artisan Patrick walks
burger and summit Linder lictor and
Carlos Goodman David Lubliner and
everyone at William Morris Jeremy Walker
and Laura Kim and everybody at Sundance
who have been so so supportive to us and
most of all our families and our friends
lawrence
mike white who gave us an incredible
script and incredible performance and
miguel who unfortunately can't be here
today but left sent a note i wish so bad
I could be with you I'm on the set of
our next film and I would complain that
Matthew didn't let me stop the
production for a couple of hours so I
could receive this award but I know that
he would never want me to stop embracing
the spirit of Independence so here I
embrace and I embrace and I thank and
wankyu all but most of all my family my
grandmother my friends our beautiful
cast and crew and you guys Mike Matthew
and Abby I'm so proud to be a part of
this team gracias Miguel Arteta thank
you all
[Applause]
and now the Spirit Awards would like to
pay tribute to a man who's been on the
front lines of the independent film
movement for over two decades
Roger Christian my name is Roger I am
the manager general manager whatever of
Laemmle sunset five theaters when I was
a child I used to think about being a
theater magic believer I used to make up
like little theater schedules and that
sort of stuff no this is the 9:45 ticket
yeah it's 8:15 now you're gonna have to
come back I'm sorry hello it's an
amusing circus here I would think I
would be very bored anyplace else there
are people with an edge to him here you
know teenagers washing come for movies
on Saturday night you know no Disney
ever okay don't forget to validate your
parking and I lie to filmmakers and tell
them how good it is or whatever you know
they've maxed out five credit cards you
know for this film you know and they've
got 12 people in a midnight show you
gotta tell them something they call up
the cashiers you know who this is their
third job you know and they have finals
tomorrow I usually hear about it that
some man was annoying man it usually
means it's the producer of the picture
why aren't we in the big house yeah you
know I mean can you spell the name
Miramax why do you think we're you're
not the big house and if you're telling
it we had 17 people that show as opposed
to 12 the first one it's like well it's
up 50% no I hate children in theaters I
really do you know I think they should
you know go somewhere else oh here comes
the some sort of god damn rag what is it
entertainment today excellence yeah I
just put it on the floor well I could
say right now that Faye Dunaway as a
theater switcher Cloris Leachman was
always pretty horrible morning it free
now elizabeth berkley there is a major
switcher she will not accept no for an
answer if it's a sold-out house she's
the one that buys to take it for the
other theater and then runs in before
you can catch her we've been told that
Dave Navarro had sex in our restroom
I'll take a medium popcorn I'm gonna go
get off install free I used to see every
movie there was I used to be one of
those who loved his own house what but
what was hot what was not was crap and
you know and be the first of the gossip
mill and and now they're just cans of
fill they carry up to
our next presenter is the Don Hutson of
the independent film community please
welcome the executive director of AFP
West Don Hudson I'm so excited to
announce a new program at if' us this
year the Los Angeles Film Festival I've
seen the upcoming films given to me by
our festival programmer Thomas Harris
and there are some great new films and
really talented new filmmakers we're
opening on April 20th at the Directors
Guild with a surprise premiere that's
terrific and Angley helped us out and
program this showcase of Hong Kong films
that inspired him making Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon thank you so much there
are so many good films I can't wait for
you to come but I have to be honest with
over 2,000 films submitted to the
festival there were some that could have
benefited from the services IFP has to
offer such as our screenwriters lab or
our directors lab or our new producers
lab in free casting rooms and free
screening rooms we even have Diane
Upson's phone number if you need a great
deal on codec film stock the list goes
on so you young filmmakers out there
take advantage of our services with the
help of everybody in this room IFE is
created to support network for
filmmakers and these services are dirt
cheap because the people in this room
are paying a ton of money for their
citrus chicken today so that you can
have these services for very affordable
cost and we can use the money all year
round so I am grateful to you I'm also
grateful to the press for writing about
the awards and about independent films
all year all year long and I thank our
sponsors who are true believers in our
cause including our principal sponsors
from turning lead coastal reserve
vineyards lupus Collis and Molly Davis
and from a bottle watch
Dada Leo and Ephraim Greenberg we have
two new wonderful premier sponsors this
year from DIRECTV Michael Thornton and
Susan Collins and from Express Michael
Wiese and Marian schwendemann and our
long-standing premier sponsors from
Motorola Jeffrey frost and David Penske
and from Entertainment Weekly John
Squires and David Morris and from Bravo
and the independent film channel
kathleen door Jonathan searing and Ed
Carroll
thanks also to our honorary chair
honorary chairs of this event Benicio
del Toro and Angela Bassett and to our
spirit awards producer for the seventh
year
Dianna's on story last I want to thank a
few studio executives who've really
helped me out with our new festival Marc
Gill at Miramax god bless you for
returning my phone calls day or night
from your airplane from your vacation
from wherever Thank You Marc Gill from
fine line who's been at such a support
of the festival and a project involved
and my dear dear friend Tom Barnard it's
no wonder that you and Michael Barker
are have such a great reputation among
filmmakers and David dinner Steen Ruth
vitally you know how much we appreciate
working with you and Tom Morten Berg
Peter rice Marcos who Bob Bernie and the
fabulous exhibitor Greg Lindley we could
not do a festival without any of you
thank you now I have to thank you so
much I have to wrap it up before I get
voted off my table so thanks
[Music]
please welcome the star of before night
falls Javier Bardem
[Applause]
[Music]
well goodnight even one given love lives
when Elena's was in prison he continued
to pour his heart and his soul into his
Brighton when I first started learning
about him I asked myself why why would a
man Jesus why would a man risk his life
yes to tell stories okay I soon came to
understand the Rinaldo did it because he
believed in the power of art he saw his
words as a weapon a beautiful weapon to
use against that tried to eliminate him
just because he was different okay
the rector children is novel he believes
in the power of art he knows he can make
us better people working with him and
playing Rinaldo change the way I look at
the world around me
I know understand that every person I
see walking down the street has a story
to tell and they are all important just
like the stories Rinaldo did until and
risk his life to tell so I'm so proud
and grateful to have been part of before
night falls
recognize this book and not that book
was the only proof to me that it was
alive this book was published in France
without permission of the Writers Union
therefore you must have had someone to
smuggle it out
you didn't go to France did you they
should be discussing this book with a
writer from you not here
[Music]
please welcome our spirit Awards
honorary co-chair and the star of the
upcoming feature the score Angela
Bassett
[Applause]
[Music]
the job of an independent film producer
is not to give the audience what it
wants it's to lead them somewhere
they've never been before producers are
the ultimate multitaskers they're
visionaries fundraisers diplomats den
mothers penny-pinchers talent scouts
cheerleaders and when the occasion
demands really really great Liars when
you think of everything it takes it's a
miracle
any independent films get made at all
the Motorola producers award which comes
with a $20,000 unrestricted grant was
created to honor those producers who's
performed miracles time and time again
the nominees are Jim McCabe producer of
stranger inside and our song Paul must
say producer of The Ballad of ramblin
Jack and sprinkle Tim Corral producer of
the opportunities and jump tomorrow
Diana Williams producer of Love Machine
and our song and the Motorola producers
award goes to Paul masae
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
thank you I've never been in front of
the camera before so a little nervous
I want to thank IFP West and I want to
thank Motorola for their incredible
generosity in sponsoring this award I've
been very fortunate over the past few
years I'm grateful to all the directors
I've been able to work with to
collaborate with and to support I want
to thank David Riker
Ayana Elliott Tom Gilroy and Jim McKay
for their friendship and their trust and
their uncompromising spirit
I want to thank IFC Films for their
unwavering support and their commitment
to truly independent filmmakers I want
to recognize Susannah Ludwig who worked
with me for over three really tough
years played a critical role in all
these projects like to thank the guys at
plantain films Hunter grey Tyler Brody
for giving me a home and I want to thank
Doug man coughing Echo Lake Jeff Lipsky
and Bob Burnie
for giving my films a home and of course
my wife Gabrielle is also my closest
friend who's always guided me to make
the right decisions and is born a larger
part of the burden for the consequence
of those decisions I adore you Gabby
Claudia thanks for keeping me sane
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm back because the Screenplay award is
coming up next and I guess I'm qualified
to introduce the presenters since one
critic wrote that my plots were the mere
clotheslines to hang my filthy wash all
writers have their clotheslines and
we're all looking for the next load of
wash no matter if it's clean or dirty oh
god we wonder what can we write next it
hasn't been done a sing-along dogma
tragedy a remake of ice castles an
all-nude pg-13 Rapunzel for hyperactive
children I don't know a postmodern Meryl
Streep splatter film whenever I start a
script I know it's time to get in my car
and drive around Baltimore snooping and
spying on people inspiration comes from
exaggerating real life I always do the
location scout first before I write any
of the narrative I picked the
neighborhood where the characters live
choose their actual homes and watch the
neighbors doing yard work going to the
store and taking out the garbage and
fantasize about the horrible and
hopefully funny things that could happen
in their lives since my new script is
about blue-collar sex addicts you know
it's a feel-good solo I feel that it's
maybe not the time to approach the
neighbors at this early stage of the
process most of the time I stay in my
plain narcotics agent car anyway writing
notes and imagining hideous scenes to
take place in their living rooms but
sometimes they see me and mistake me for
I don't know a Snoopy insurance agent or
worse yet a flasher I peel out with my
ideas and hope they don't remember me in
four or five months when the real
location manager knocks on their door
eavesdropping has always been a really
important source material for dialogue
just open your ears and pretend you're
not listening and you'll hear people say
the most lunatic things that you can use
in a fancy restaurant in Baltimore I
heard the waiter ask the woman would you
care for dessert and she said classily
Christ no I'm bloated I and in a local
supermarket I saw this beautiful angelic
child wander away from her mother for a
minute and the mother snow get over here
you little ass
God you know really damaged the child's
self-esteem but gave me some sparkling
new dialogue really you know let's talk
let's talk about this nc-17 rating it
isn't it time that writers band together
to rehabilitate this ridiculous stigma
of the supposed adult rating a European
intellectual I know just arrived in
America and he saw a marquee that said I
could hardly speak English the marquee
said two adult hits and he rushed inside
expecting intelligent well-written
thought-provoking American movies isn't
this what the nc-17 rating should really
mean face it face it there's only one
taboo left in movies and that's why the
MPAA is in business to stop Hollywood
a-list stars from having real sex on
film with screen actor guild approval of
penetration now it's already happening
in Europe and I guarantee it will happen
in the United States in the next decade
but movie stars we need your help
writers can think it up but you have to
do it once the star legitimizes reality
sex there will be nothing left for the
MPAA to fear and the curse of nc-17 will
be meaningless
have courage critics and the American
public will accept you in taboo breaking
material as long as it's done in a
clever ironic way I salute whoever takes
this chance who will it be Chloe how
about you geoffrey rush come on
jennifer Tilly go down in film history
no let the Golden Age of sensor free
independent film begin think of the new
edge you'll require when you casually
mention to the press on your nest prep
on your nest junket if done tastefully
with a good script and a visionary
director I have no problem with
penetration just think you might win the
next Independent Spirit Award thank you
and and now to give out the next spirit
award from everything put together Radha
Mitchell and pass Spirit Award winner
Jason lead
[Music]
as John explained a good screenwriter
doesn't just sit in his house and type
he goes out in public listens to your
private conversations add some magic and
then tragedy 9 bucks to go and see it
the nominees for Best Screenplay are
Valerie Bremen for love and sex
Raymond's of colita for two family house
Robert Dylan for waking the dead in it
run again for me
Mike white for Chuck and buck
and screw to Wyatt goes to Kenneth one
again
[Applause]
[Music]
well I want to thank the IFP for this
this is just wonderful I think any
screenwriter can appreciate what I owe
to my producers john hart jeff sharp
larry meistrich and barbara Dafina for
making this movie and for trusting me to
direct it and also what I owe to David
dinner Steen and Ruth vitally at
paramount classics for distributing the
film I also think that any screenwriter
and director can appreciate that I owe
everything to Mark Ruffalo and Laura
Linney
I I don't know whether I'm more proud to
be associated with them or more proud
that they were in my movie were more
delighted as an artist that they brought
the script to life the way that they did
also Matthew Broderick and wonderful
Rory Culkin and and John Tenney and my
beloved wife J Smith Cameron I also like
to thank my agents at William Morris
David Lubliner Dave workshafter and
George Lane and thank you very much
there without the independent film
movement I wouldn't be here at all thank
you please welcome the co-stars of love
and sex and the upcoming feature May
famke janssen and Jon Favreau
[Music]
the Sonny & Cher of independent film
doesn't even say that up to here oh so
IBM let's see the category of Best Debut
performance presents the widest variety
of nominees some roles require the
simplicity of delicate naturalism like
the kids from George Washington others
require months of sweat and research
getting in the face of intimidating
violent men in a world where women are
not welcome of course I'm referring to
Chuck and buck the nominees for Best
Debut performance are Curtis cotton the
third Candice
Evan offski Michael handy Donald Holden
I hope they have enough statues back
there Amy and Joo and lean for George
Washington and they're kissing my last
huh my friend George said that he was
gonna live to be a hundred years old he
said he said that he was gonna be the
President of the United States I wanted
to see him lead a parade and wave a flag
on the 4th of July
[Music]
Rory Kelton for you can count on me no I
wasn't even born yet
were you ever in the army no my father
was in the army
I know unfortunately he didn't fight in
Vietnam either were you friends with him
not really I mean we had some friends in
common I guess I didn't like him very
much
why not well he wasn't very likeable
Michelle Rodriguez girl fight who says
he'll be the only one fighting I'm sorry
dad but I haven't trained all this time
to be stuck in a ring with a girl stuck
with a girl okay stuck with you
you're afraid I might win no we're gonna
play it all manly and protective on me
now look I'm just being honest you're
just like any other guy yeah what kind
of a guy goes around beating up a girl
that Betty what what she got all those
love songs from her mama do you know any
more balanced love songs I know lots of
I know Lord Randle Jack wanna sail and
two sisters
I'm a young Emily would you sing two
sisters please it's all right there o
sister o sister come go with me
and Michael White for Chuck and buck
putting on a play you are yeah I was
thinking about those plays we used to
put on I was thinking about you know the
devil and the reindeer the devil and the
reindeer uh-huh it was a they both have
horns so they team up against Santa
[Applause]
and the spirit award goes to michelle
rodriquez for girl fight
excepting for Michelle Rodriguez is
director carne Kusama
[Applause]
[Music]
hi Michelle can't be here tonight she's
filming in Berlin she gave me a quote I
know she's gonna be delighted and very
surprised she wants to wish everyone
peace love and prosperity in the spirit
of revolution that was one of the
producers Martha Griffin I'm Karan
Kazama the director I'm sure that
Michelle would wouldn't know how to be
speechless but I'll keep it short I'm
sure she's very very honored and thank
thanks you all
Thanks in the bedroom would you consider
yourself a crouching tiger or a hidden
dragon
what threat what kind of Tiger Crouching
dragon a crouching tiger a crouching
tiger because I like to pounce on my
prey dragon please welcome the writer
producer of Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon
James Shamus
[Applause]
[Music]
in Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon Angley
has concocted to tell the whole world
can relate to the story of a middle-aged
man portrayed by Chalian fat who
although he's always in his pajamas has
never been laid his phallic symbol has
been stolen by a teenaged girl who wears
a little black kerchief over her face as
if anybody could be fooled as to her
identity eventually he gets the sword
back but he's killed by a really
pissed-off middle-aged woman ladies and
gentlemen Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
[Applause]
yeah but you but yet it's Emil
[Music]
here's last year's winner for Best
Supporting female for boys don't cry
and this year's foreign film nominee for
the war zone please welcome Chloe
Sevigny at Tim Roth
[Music]
are you here to present the Award for
Best Supporting Actress the nominees are
back Pat Carroll for song catcher how
can I make money for singing my mama
used to sing those songs rocking the
youngins to sleep and leading the cows
home dr. ermias can you kindly to leave
Tom I can you give my songs to anybody
that I want to are you crying I am
massage it's suppertime and lilies Joe
Namath Oh No thank you mrs. Butler
really I should be heading back to the
school you can take my songs and refuse
the hospitality of my home
well I'm never
jennifer connelly for requiem for a
dream when you're home so when so you
hold out right fairy
can you come today
Marcia Gay Harden Pollock I believe
Jackson you painting and you you need
need need need anywhere else I don't
want to be with anyone else but that's
all I can
pay on Tavares for Chuck and buck
they're in the poorest it's like
paradise right this horrible wicked
witch woman appears they've trespassed
she casts a spell on both of them and
makes the paint'll stupid and she turns
Frank into a
which is like castration she casts
traits him what do you mean like she
takes his penis away
seventy-four crashing Tiger Hidden
Dragon
[Applause]
[Music]
and the Spirit Award goes to
[Applause]
[Music]
I mentioned out-educated yeah I didn't
expect I'm gonna win education I'm very
very happy Peshawar how long the Louella
line between the film and the 60 ding
the six month of shooting the film young
chef Alejandra I've learned so much
yamato damashii TNT ha ha watandar so
she tinea t she hiring howdy
it made me become stronger and and
consider other people yah I shall wait
Yong Chi ciaochao ciaochao coming home
you learn to accept the challenge
Kancha without on the gpio change
attention you want to thank the
producers mr. Shirley Shirley Kong and
bill Kong can share us a meeting Yankel
antiochus thank you can't Sony Pictures
Classics kayo
do what show you Georgina Diane Lee
ization
and who helped me so much director of
only see on your TV attack any good so I
hope I can work with you again
[Music]
the project it was Red Dead Boys people
are certainly affected by before night
falls there is a correlation between
food and the type of film double dildo
and requiem sent people to the snack bar
fast in that particular feeling they
were violated you know they would come
out there was this major sense of
violation but we sort of enjoyed that
chocolate that cutting edge indie film
that it is I cannot have another senior
lady come up to me with tears their eye
and tell me how much it's been a special
day for her it makes me want to vomit so
did you like the movie what you see
Pollock chocolate okay alright from the
contender please welcome Christian
Slater
[Applause]
Hey my name is Christian and I am the
invincible sword goddess that's right so
I'm here to present the also by the way
I'm gonna be working with avi Lerner
soon so I was he's not such a bad guy I
mean come on we're shooting in Bulgaria
but it's all right not so bad
I'm here to present the Award for Best
Cinematography and these guys are truly
the ones you want to have be your friend
on the set I mean I myself have coming
to work a few times and had to go right
to the cinematographer and say please
what can you do
help me out you know came in once with a
ingrown hair on my neck it was like a
goiter you know shooting out of mine it
was horrible but somehow the way these
guys light these things it's miraculous
really so I ended up looking good I
don't think anybody will be the wiser so
anyway the nominees for Best
Cinematography are
Liuba for shadow of the vampire
[Music]
John de Boorman for Hamlet's
[Applause]
Matthieu liberty or requiem for a dream
Tim or for George Washington
[Applause]
[Music]
divya Perez grab a and Guillermo wrote
saw for before night falls
and the Spirit Award goes to
Matthew Liberty for recommend for drea
[Applause]
[Music]
whoo John Waters I'm addicted to
cigarettes PlayStation 2 and
hallucinogens I promised myself that I
would not forget to thank my beautiful
wife Lisa and my my babies Ezekiel and
Audrey my mother Dina my brother David
and most of all my father Johnny who's
not with us today but Eric and Darren
I'm so appreciative of the collaboration
we have as filmmakers but even more so
was as friends and thank you again for
inviting me to help make this film
Palmer West Jonah Smith beau Flynn Nick
Wechsler Scott Franklin's got Vogel
who'd I forget a mere Bill
Jeremy barber all you guys thank you so
much for having me I want to thank my
crew I'd like to actually you know
dedicate a lot of this award I wouldn't
have it if it wasn't for the work of
Clint Manziel J Rabinowitz and James
chin Lin who's not here today as well
my crew Gary Marton Phil testa Jim
Bartolomeo thank you so much for
supporting me even though the ideas
might have seemed a little crazy at the
time
I don't know I'm forgetting somebody my
agent patty Mack Colleen Dolan and Thank
You IFP he'd laid down the law in Lone
Star
she laid everybody and drop-dead
gorgeous but I just say that please
welcome Chris Cooper and Allison Janney
[Applause]
[Music]
there has been a lot of talk here today
about artistic integrity and gosh it was
a labor of love yeah but let's face it
working in independent film is just a
stepping stone toward erecting your own
superhero movie why right now Sam Raimi
is working on spider-man with Tobey
Maguire and two of today's nominated
directors are also making movies based
on comic books unli is working on the
Incredible Hulk
Darren Aronofsky is making the next
Batman movie as a matter of fact Chris I
think we have one of the first original
production stills from that movie you
know ahh --mess all this makes me think
what next
Todd Salons Wonder Woman I don't know
she looks really ticked off doesn't like
when people call her wiener dog
then there's Christopher guest's
improvisational Superman finally a
chance to see Eugene Levy's package and
nominee Miguel Arteta could go from
Chuck and buck to the Green Hornet and
his trusty sidekick Kato and this last
one is pretty far-fetched but you never
know
and now on to the Award for Best Foreign
Film which we should clarify does not
include film set on Krypton or in any
other parallel universe and the nominees
are dancer in the dark director Lars von
Trier in the mood for love director Wong
kar-wai the terrorist director Santosh
Sivan
a time for drunken horses director bomb
on bo-buddies
and the war zone director Tim Roth
and the spirit award goes to dancer in
the dark director Lars von Trier
apparently we now know where all these
stray gift bags will be going Lars is
unable to be here today to accept but we
accept this award on his behalf please
welcome the upcoming feature welcome to
Collinwood Isaiah Washington
[Music]
[Applause]
mmm George Washington is yes definitely
definitely yeah George Washington is
this year's Cinderella story and since
that I've seen it is definitely one of a
personal story for me since I grew up in
the south this made out it was made in
North Carolina by the first time
director David Gordon Green yeah for
$100,000 which means we could literally
pass a hat around now and set him up for
a sequel the film caught the attention
of a few film critics
Roger Ebert and Elvis Mitchell of the
New York Times got into the New York
Film Festival and here it is one of the
Spirit Awards Best Feature nominees
when I look at my friends I know there's
goodness I can look at their feet or
when I hold their hand I pretend I can
see the bones inside your son is that he
right mrs. Richardson my friend George
he told me that he could read God's mind
he told me he knew what guy was gonna
create who he was gonna let it let die
and stuff like that
[Music]
well since the show is about half way
over I thought I'd check out what's
going on at the bar so I hear you've
created some specialty drinks for
tonight yeah that's right mr. waters
this is the Chuck and buck which is just
your basic Bloody Mary but with a stalk
of celery and a shot of Spanish Fly have
you heard of the requiem for a dream you
basically just pour all the liquor in
one glass and then hit them over the
head with a bottle
sounds messy
well speaking of messy uh you know has
anybody had one too many I mean drunk
celebrities make great cutaways I really
shouldn't say it's kind of industry did
I mention that I'm casting a film I'm
out here Illeana Douglas hammered she's
been back five times at least that's
good to know we'll keep an eye on her
certainly and now to present our next
award she's just wrapped the feature
that cat's meow he's about to open and
blow please welcome Jennifer Tilly and
Paul Reubens
[Music]
hello I'm Jennifer Tilly and this is
gone positive do your thing Paul so
we're here to present the Movado
somewhat to a watch award and I'm Paul
show them your movado watch that they
gave you free of charge just before the
ceremony thank you the mo Vaughn is
someone to watch award honors and
emerging filmmakers whose talent
ambition leads us to believe we'll be
seeing a lot more of them in the future
the award includes a $20,000
unrestricted grant funded by Movado
which means that the winner can do
whatever they want with the money no
questions asked there is one small catch
stuff since is sponsored by Movado the
winner will be fitted with a special
watch that has a built-in tracking
device a camera and a mini electric
taser do you know what a Taser is Paul
no it's a small electronic device it's
used to shock somebody into submission
my boyfriend and I use it a lot insects
play
mmm-hmm we here at IFP get the feeling
that you are slacking off we'll just
give you a little friendly shock as if
to say what are you doing watching
coyote ugly on pay-per-view three lap
dances is enough for one night go home
and write something memorable
it's just our cheerful way of keeping
you focused on your art because we can
and we really do care now
the three nominees who will surely not
need to be tased and can enjoy the watch
for the beautiful timepiece it is our
Marc Forster director of everything put
together
[Applause]
Ray Romano of everybody let know I'm
sorry
dan McCoy I'm sorry dan McCormack
director of other voices mia track and
chair director of funny
and the Movado someone to watch award
goes to
[Applause]
[Music]
now thank you so much
you know it's amazing a Jennifer and
Paul here sending me giving me this
award thank you so much to the IFP and
Committee which nominated the film and
and myself and thank you for giving the
award there's so many people I need to
thank on this journey we are all on and
I hope I don't forget anybody so please
forgive me if I do first I want to thank
Catherine Boyd burns who shared her idea
for the film with me and her husband
Adam for gosh the three of us wrote the
script together it was a wonderful
experience and wanted to thank them both
very much
I want to thank Sean first and Radha
Mitchell who committed to the movie and
made the movie happen
I want to thank Roberta Shafer Matt
chassis Jill service on Megan Mullally
just everybody who put their heart into
this movie because it was just truly a
labor of love and my family my loved one
in my life Renee Supriya who always
gives me much and and then one other
person Robert Lou Dreyfus who was my
benefactor without him I would have
never been able to come to the States
and was able to pay all the bills for me
to study film and be here and that's
pretty much thank you so much and for
all the friends who always supported me
throughout all these years thank you
she's the star he's a nominee today for
the gift please welcome Kirsten Dunst
and Giovanni Ribisi
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been said that you have a lifetime
to create your first film and a year to
create your second I'm the rest of your
life to complain about how they both
premiered on Showtime
here are five nominees whose first
features reflect literally decades of
thought feeling and imagination and we
can't wait to see what they come up with
next the nominees for Best first feature
are boiler room director Ben younger
producer Suzanne Todd and Jennifer say
money can't buy happiness look at the
smile on my face here - here baby
you have to be closing all the time and
be aggressive we're not a push place is
going not she revealing stocks that
really miss kids college punk yes my
first account baby you're one of us know
this kid is really good okay he's gonna
go down hard girl fight director Karan
Kusama producers Maggie Renzi Sarah
green and Martha Griffin
we know him
inside you know yourself then maybe you
shouldn't be a boxer and that's all you
need
[Applause]
love and basketball
director Tina Prince by flood producer
Spike Lee in Santa come into any draft
going pro so that's it
just forget about you and me
[Music]
I never knew anyone loved ball as much
as you I've loved you since I was 11 and
it just won't go away
I play one game one one for what
new huh visit director producer Jordan
Walker Pearlman she looked up at me and
called out to me Alexander
[Music]
you'd come I know what would be the
first thing you would do this board
grants you role producers John and heart
Jeffrey sharp Robert Athena and Larry
mice you know you're the worst manager
we've ever had this is incredible
that is not what I mean
I got a hundred bucks here says me and
my nephew can beat anybody in here only
we gotta get the next game and the
Spirit Award goes to you can count on me
[Applause]
[Music]
well I'm supposed to speak for the group
this is really extraordinary I don't
actually know what to say
just want to thank my producers again my
wonderful producers and again the cast
and gee everybody I don't know what to
say
this has been an incredible experience
and I just thank you all very much I'm
very overwhelmed thank you
[Applause]
please welcome the director of this
year's Sundance opener my first mr.
Christine Lahti and the president of
eiope West's Board of Directors von
DeCurtis ha
[Applause]
the independent film movement in this
country began with documentary
filmmakers like Robert Flaherty and
Peter Lorentz so it's only fitting that
IFP West has added a new category this
year for documentary filmmakers today's
5 nominated films don't just tell it
like it is they show it the nominees for
Best Documentary are
dark days director mark singer
the eyes of Tammy Faye directors Randy
Barbado and Fenton Bailey long day's
journey in today directors Francis Reid
and Deborah Hoffman paragraph 175
directors Rob Epstein and Jeffrey
Friedman sound and fury director Josh
Aronson and the Spirit Award goes to
dark days mark singer
[Applause]
[Music]
well I'm really nervous first I want to
acknowledge all of the other
documentaries here and um I feel really
humbled just that this film is
recognized amongst them man this has
been a really long road for me and it
was six and a half years ago it was the
first time that I went into the tunnel
and we didn't have any idea how this was
going to turn out to be honest I'm still
surprised that the the film even came
out what we shot but I'm standing up
here alone but there were so many people
behind the scenes that you don't see
that without their love and support this
this would never have happened and
there's so many of them that I'm scared
to start naming them because I know I'm
going to forget someone and lastly I
want to thank everybody in the tunnel
who trusted me with their lives and show
me what it means to be human
thank you very much for this please
welcome the coast guard himself Forrest
Whitaker
[Applause]
[Music]
Gustad play a hitman who adheres
religiously to the hog quarry the book
of the samurai in it there's a passage
that reads one should make his decisions
within the space of seven breaths it is
a matter of being determined and having
the spirit to break right through to the
other side that's certainly the approach
that Jim Jarmusch took to this project
into directing it what began as a casual
series of conversations between the two
of us evolved into a living breathing
work of art it's a film about the codes
that people follow and what happens when
they break them Ghost Dog fuses the
worlds of 18th century Japanese history
and contemporary gangster life and sets
it all to a hip-hop beat it's a film
about rules that doesn't seem to follow
any of them here is Ghost Dog the way of
the samurai my mom says you never talked
to nobody and you got no friends I don't
know your mom is that true though
what thank you never talk to nobody and
you got no friends no I'm talking to you
right yeah
the way of the samurai is one of
immediacy and it is best to - in head
warm you want the combs like a
revengeful
ghost and shows great determination
though his head is cut off
he should not die this is a substance of
the way of the samurai what is that
supposed to mean it's poetry the poetry
[Music]
use the word Jarmusch in a sentence I
woke up this morning tonight Jarmusch
myself my boyfriend I jar mooshed
all night long I am jar moosh what the
hell does jar bouche mean she had too
big jar mushas she's the contender and
he's a force to contend with
please welcome Joan Allen and James
Woods
[Music]
I'm sorry I'm sorry it's so so
embarrassing I'm sorry you know there's
a strike coming on it could be sorry
stop sorry you know you might want to
get some work hello I'm sorry about this
Joan it's like Roger no I'm I'm here I'm
kind of busy actually worth it yeah yeah
just I don't know some pasta and salad
would be fine I guess
okay Roger from the sunset okay yeah I
love you too okay bye okay thank you
sorry but he's very needy as you could
see from the clips okay it was either
that or reading this crap up here okay
come on
one or the other all right James and I
are here to present the Award for Best
Director and I am fortunate enough to be
standing next to the Marlon Brando of
actresses I got it okay and let me just
say something this is that propel of
nothing okay when we did Nixon it was
like 28 testosterone written guys like
trying to like you know vie to be sort
of the star of a picture and Oliver
sitting there like a dog chewing on
peanut butter trying to get his thoughts
together and Joan was just sort of sail
through it all you know she was the most
fabulous and you know I know what all
the critics say but I'm a gamblin man I
hope you kick some ass tomorrow night
[Applause]
and and after that the nominees are
Darren Aronofsky for requiem for a dream
Miguel Arteta for Chuck and buck
Christopher guest's for Best in Show
Hong Li for coaching Tiger Hidden Dragon
Julian Schnabel for before night falls
and honorable mention to Sofia Coppola
but that's another story and the there
is no surprise he wrongly for Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
my deepest appreciation to Independent
Spirit Award for treating our guests
with Chinese food in the doggie bags you
don't know how much that meant to me I
mean for years I've been resisting to
join the Union here in the States
because there's one regulation in the
Union that says the Chinese food is
illegitimate to treat your crew in a
second meal that used to upset me so
much they may be cheaper but the good
food
[Applause]
standing here anyway standing here with
this award I have one confession to make
I have never been to sound dance what
I'm really driving at is that I don't
know really what independent spirit
really means to me I'm very confused for
years people ask me are independent or
make movie for Hollywood or you're
Taiwanese filmmaker a Chinese filmmaker
and I used to work out something like
I'm a New York filmmaker I figure that I
sort of sum up everything but I'm
probably making hope in in LA next year
so that won't be useful anymore I don't
come choose because I think nobody can
really be independent in making movies
we all rely on each other it's a
collaborative process not only in the
making also distributing selling
financing we rely on each other so
really what independent spirit meant to
me is that I think as a filmmaker you
have to keep in your heart you have to
make something that make a difference
and and be interesting and inspiring I
think as long as you intend to do that
you're okay for that I thank you the
Independent Spirit Award and this honor
I also want to give it to everybody who
helped me make this movie this is the
war is yours thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not my pleasure to introduce a true
independent film pioneer in films like
faces and a woman under the influence
made with her husband John Cassavetes
she introduced the world to a style of
acting they had never seen before
please welcome Jenna Rowland
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much I'm I'm very happy to
be here with you I just love the
Independent Spirit Awards what I'm going
to do is introduce the best actors in
lead role
the first is Javier Bardem before
nightfall I want to tell you that I make
a forgiveness I wanted to say mom how
pretty you are today you look like one
of those women that you can only see in
Christmas cards but I said nothing
because of the knot in my throat that
was very nice
what's your name renal marinas who
Brutus I did it's my own from anomaly
and what do you call this novel singing
from the well are you a student
yes I am an agricultural accountant
[Music]
the next actors Adrien Brody restaurant
is she am I happy she's in love with me
and - should I be in love with her
either like a little girl you know the
mix after is Billy Crudup Jesus is son
what we've seen before
Louis Whitney's back oh look what they
gave me I was asking them when we die if
there's an ending to everything we know
and if there is then why don't we just
die now you know die to everything we
know I mean maybe maybe living and dying
are the same thing and maybe the fact
that we've turned them into two
different things is why we feel so lost
the next actor is Hill Harper the visit
I need to know one thing the day came
and I can at least make some sense out
of it myself and if mom and dad ever
found out I had this disease they say it
was God's punishment you don't know that
in your heart you don't know that and in
their heart they don't know if I raped
that woman
the final actor is Mark Ruffalo you can
count on me they got a Titus movie and I
refuse to work on through stomach Terry
but it's really good to know wherever I
am and whatever stupid she's been doing
that you're back at my home rooting for
me it's all gonna be all right Sammy
comparatively
[Music]
and the spirit award goes to Javier
[Applause]
[Music]
well I guess can we repeat the stop
before so again do it even worse it's an
honor for me to have this award because
I live in Spain I live in Madrid I
usually go to the movies to see
independent movies which I like most
more more much more than the big studio
movies I don't know why maybe because
they are quite more interesting and to
be here and receive this is like
something like a pleasure thank you very
much for this and I never like to thanks
to my mother
which I love Pilar my father my brother
and sister their families to Cristina
which I love but really Elise I guess I
don't forget anybody here okay and I
have the least excuse me I'm quite
nervous here now this is the theme from
before so it was suppose for me to know
alive heart okay my friends that maybe
are watching TV hi hola como estas
Karratha who's my acting teacher
margarita who's a very good friend of
mine and here we go Julian man
Julian's novel thank you
I love you thank you very much thank you
you are one of the greatest persons I
ever met personally as the nature you
are even better but I mean as a person
you are a great human being and your
heart is as big as your body which is a
lot you are amazing thank you
and John Keeley the producer fireline
ball cutter ski laughs another myth
and of course the one who really
deserves this award because I'm only
natural and natural are usually treated
like gods we are nobody else but people
who say lines in movies this thing is
for another anus who gave His life for
freedom
please welcome the star of requiem for a
dream Jared Leto
[Music]
[Applause]
when people who haven't seen requiem for
a dream asked me what it's about I tell
them the truth
it's about misery suffering degradation
it's a one-way ticket to hell a film
that kicks you in the stomach spits in
your face and expects you to sit there
and take it it's a movie that doesn't
apologize for telling the truth requiem
for a dream was adapted from the novel
by Hubert Selby jr. one of the great
American writers he's not here tonight
but it tells a story of four desperate
characters and what happens when their
American dream becomes a nightmare for
me making this film was this is the
Darrin miserable painful depressing and
one of the most remarkable times of my
life so to the faint of heart out there
you better go to the snack bar here's
[Applause]
just like that she went to a doctor and
he gave her pills you don't want to eat
in the morning blue in the afternoon
Islands in the evening just like that
one two three four
[Music]
please welcome the star of Knockaround
guys and the original independent Dennis
Hopper
[Music]
the line based on a true story thrown
around a lot in our business because
there's nothing more compelling than the
truth today's five nominees for direct
for the Direct TV IFC truer than fiction
award understand that they've each
demonstrated extraordinary promise in
the field of documentary filmmaking
today we'd like to honor one of them
with a truer than fiction award which
comes with an unrestricted grant of
$20,000 funded by DirecTV in the
independent film channel and the
nominees are Jim Coan and Peter cylinder
or Benjamin smoke Shelley done Fremont
and Vincent Fremont for pie-in-the-sky
the Brigid Berlin story David Shapiro on
Laurie
Gwen Shapiro for keep the river on your
right a modern cannibal tale james
rollin whitney for just Melvin and the
DirecTV IFC truer than fiction award
goes to David Shapiro and Laurie Gwynn
Shapiro to keep the river in your light
a modern cannibal tale
[Applause]
[Music]
when we first started this project six
years ago we went to people for funding
the most common response and there were
dozens of people who said no way was who
wants to see a film about a 74 year old
gay Jewish ex cannibal I guess that's
what independent film means we just want
to thank first we want to thank the
other films that are in our category
they're all masterful and we're honored
to be among your company and we'd like
to thank the Independent Spirit Award
IFC Films Bob Burnie and Jonathan serang
who's a champion of this project from
day one so thank you Jonathan I also
like to thank our two incredible
executive producers Peter Broderick of
next wave films and Chris rooms we like
to thank the people who have supported
us my husband Paul our Associate
Producer and David's girlfriend Kim
whicker's and we also like to dedicate
this to Tobias niebaum who's watching
home in Greenwich Village and today is
his 80th birthday so happy birthday to
bias
[Applause]
please welcome last year's Best Actress
winner for boys don't cry and the
director of the upcoming feature frailty
everyone's favorite Bill and Hillary
Hillary Swank and Bill Paxton it's great
to be here today to celebrate the spirit
of independent filmmaking in recognition
of that spirit we're here to present the
award for best female lead when you take
on a role in an independent film you
never imagine that you're going to end
up at an award show your biggest hope is
that anyone will actually see it here
are the five women we are honoring for
their outstanding work today the
nominees for best female lead are Joan
Allen for The Contender
I am fully prepared to step down but my
personal life and my past or just that
but I will do whatever you say
Ellen Burstyn for what Liam before dream
I like the way I feel I like thinking
about the red dress and the television
you your father know when I kept the Sun
I smile stained I wouldn't be start at
least you got your priorities straight
I've never asked you to choose never
have to I'm a ballplayer if anybody
knows what that means it should be you
Laura Linney for you can count on me and
I got all these things I got to do back
in Worcester Oh
so I'm probably not gonna be able to
stay for more than a day ourselves oh I
mean I'm trying to keep their schedule
aside oh I did that's all right it's a
very worthy story but I won't trouble
you with it right now
or two family house they'd see what kind
of mind that needs taking care of
yeah well this one can't go in the tank
like all the others
it won't we're all meant for something
particular this is what you're meant for
you think so huh I know so mr. visalo
here the war goes to Ellen Burstyn
requiem for a dream
[Music]
[Applause]
I just can't tell you how much I wanted
this thank you for every single person
who voted for me congratulations to all
the other nominees all of your
performances were wonderful and
deserving thank you Hubert Selby jr. for
writing the amazing book
Thank You Darren Aronofsky for your
genius
and for giving me the part of my career
thank you Eric Watson for being our wise
counselor thank you to the crew who held
me in their collective arms like a giant
Big Brother
thank you to my son Jefferson and his
wife Tricia for my granddaughter
I love my profession I love what we do
it's an honour to reflect the spirit of
humanity back to itself please welcome
with all his clothes on the starved
quills Geoffrey Rush
[Music]
good afternoon during the show you've
seen clips from the five great films
nominated for Best Feature now let's see
who actually won the nominees are before
night falls producer Jon Killick
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon produces
bill Kong sue Lee Kong and Angley George
Washington produces David Gordon Green
such a WM EULA and Lisa muskrat
ghosts of the way of the samurai
produces jim jarmusch and richard guy
[Music]
requiem for dream produces Eric Watson
and Hammer Wes
and the spirit award goes to Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you where's I just want
to thank Michael Parker company Robinson
James Sheamus and David Indy and all the
cussing whoo thank you
I'm just wondering how come we didn't
make to the Foreign Film category
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it better that's it everybody
goodnight thank you for coming get more
out of life go see a cheap movie
[Applause]